let's go to peru now where the
government says an offshore oil spill is
twice as big as previously reported it's
now confirmed that 12 000 barrels of oil
leaked into the sea two weeks ago at a
refinery owned by the spanish oil
company repsol peru's government has
demanded compensation but repsol says it
was an act of nature
they have an almost impossible job
cleaning up after this ecological
disaster
a volcanic eruption thousands of
kilometers away in tonga triggered waves
that hit a tanker off peru's coast
causing this severe oil leak
but the fishing communities blame repsol
the oil company that owns the refinery
where the accident happened
[Music]
so far it's been two weeks since the oil
spill and no one has been held
accountable there should be someone in
prison right now
this needs to stop the poor animals the
fish
we are supporting the municipalities by
donating hair to clean these beaches
president pedro castillo has toured the
affected area and he too wants answers
i would like to confirm the seriousness
and responsibility of this government to
make the company comply with its
criminal
civil and administrative obligations
we cannot have a six c
a peruvian judge has banned repsol's
regional executives from going abroad as
investigators look into the incident
repsol says it's cooperating with the
government and is also focused on
cleaning up the environment
you